what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season five episode
nope four episode six today John how's
it going uh I'm good how are you I'm
doing swell it's called monster in the
closet I'm excited I got a monster in
the closet you know what I'm mean trying
to peek through at any moment you know
what I'm saying is it an innuendo maybe
or am I talking about an actual physical
monster that lurks in the closet that I
keep trapped there that I can unleash at
any moment is that
a metaphor to
can't be clear YouTube will be really
sensitive if I'm clear so we'll leave it
at there's a an actual monster in my
bedroom closet literally yeah so leave a
like let's get to it and you can catch
the full length Reaction watch as long
as on patreon
I'm so scared there's a place through my
claws oh monsters aren't real my little
pierogi but I saw it it was big and a
Harry
nightmare buddy I'm gonna open this
closet it's Jake in there show you that
there's nothing in there don't do that
but see nothing oh
[Music]
what's he doing and there's a great cold
open what were you doing in Boyle's
closet in the first place oh I still had
a key from when I was crashing there
last year and I wanted to shower and
anoint my body with essential oils
before I saw Rosa duh anointed where
have you been all this time Vegas has
been locked up for a month I was in
prison in Uzbekistan it's actually not
as bad as it sounds
I deserve that
smuggling ammo to a rebel group flying
an old Soviet prop plane they tortured
us made me eat my co-pilot's tongue now
I've got a taste for it the importance
oh no
son of a [ __ ] you're the son of a [ __ ]
yes we will
violet yeah this is awkward I'm sure
they'll stop soon nope and it's
escalating let's go never stop never
stopping when I was in that Uzbek prison
my face was being beaten in I realized
life is funny that's what you realize
and it's short we're picking up where we
left off when Adrian went into hiding
we're getting married tomorrow no no way
and Lush and romantic just like a Nancy
Myers movie She's our favorite director
oh I love You've Got Mail that's Nora
Ephron you idiot
planning a wedding like that in 14 hours
would be the greatest organizational
challenge in history how are you gonna
do it just kind of hoping you would I
thought I was supposed to get you guys
the wedding present the next 14 hours
are going to be hell but in the end you
will have the satisfaction of knowing
that you've finally done something
worthwhile with your lives
I need to go to newstead of New York I
gotta pick up a pair of ruby earrings
who stutters like six hours away I'm not
so sure we can get there in back in time
my grandmother wore them on her wedding
day and said they blessed her Union do
you want this Union to be blessed or do
you want this you need to be freaking
unblessed blessed totally blessed I'll
do it it's blessed oh Gina's got jelly
beans pimento bad sorry Gina
you should come with us on this trip you
know in case he starts acting fat crab
Looney Tunes yes do it well you're not
the basis of a character on an Empire
Jake but I don't throw that in your face
every damn day so you will come with us
yeah I'll be there you the man bye girl
see you in the car girl
I've generated a detailed timeline
broken down into 30 second increments to
keep us on wow we're already 16.5
increments behind schedule Terry feels
overwhelmed good use it Neil Armstrong
was overwhelmed when he walked on the
moon but you know what he did he walked
on the moon
Colleen Hitchcock you're in charge of
seating smart move Amy I've been called
the Leonardo da Vinci is sitting on my
ass great nice question you can help me
decorate I mentioned disposal just tell
me what to do I'm here to implement your
vision well we just want to keep it
classy got it balloon arch what say no
more it's done have a couple bellinis
and just relax peach juice and champagne
peach juice and champagne one of my six
come on just try it it's what Nancy
Myers would drink fine
for Nancy for Nancy you sure we're
looking for 381 because 381 is looking a
little crispy oh no oh how did this
happen uh it's okay everything's gonna
be fine we'll think of something all
right this is a sign from the Universe I
can't marry Rosa no guys
the wedding's off no goddammers the sign
was real if I ignore it and marry Rosa
anyway I'm basically asking the universe
to stomp on my balls okay good point
James Bond style you're right the
marriage is cursed no you ain't in wrong
I'm sorry Jake it's an omen and I'm not
taking your side against the universe as
it's hundreds of years old
true that
so the earrings maybe somebody bought
them before the place burned down right
we could track them down and looky here
I just got the owner's name that's good
right okay maybe there is a little bit
of hope your damn right there is second
Universe are you
it's better
I think it's a little off you know
what's off your mouth why Jake lets your
stupid tongue anywhere near him I'll
never know nope I forgot the sugar
that's on me
there's no form more graceful than the
arch No Object more Whimsical than the
balloon you and I think that but what
will Rose I think good point Rosa would
want a much much bigger balloon arch
back to the balloon store
we've got a problem what Rose is drunk
Rosa no how Bellini's rule Nancy Myers
you've done it again you Saucy [ __ ]
do it your earrings they didn't survive
the fire oh no this is really bad well
not necessarily I mean maybe the
universe allowed something else she's
wearing like a rabbit's foot I don't
think you understand how pawn shops work
I don't think you understand how they
work yours burned down
ouch she's got the earrings she stole
all the merch and then burned down the
store she's wearing a necklace that I
also Pawn there are you sure it's the
same necklace uh yeah Jake I once
punched you through a guy's throat so
I'm pretty sure I remember
don't bother let's just kick down the
door and take back what's mine no no no
no that's a bad idea he's right just use
the lattice the upstairs windows open
nice
how come you and Genevieve our nerd huh
uh you know it's complicated no it's not
it's easy bring it down here we'll get
married yeah right she doesn't want that
oh that sounds
[Music]
oh no no everything's great with us I
mean if it was up to me we'd get hitched
but she had a really bad divorce so oh
I'm sorry does that upset you I'm good
yeah I'm good I'm so sad
rain stick keeping it no you're not that
is a crime untrue once you steal
something none of your stuff belongs to
you I've heard that too no you haven't
no one has put that down okay
you cannot be a quieter robber you told
me to put it
hi we met earlier you're breaking into
my house or you breaking into our house
just stay down right
I found the earrings two Dinos get in
here so you can watch me light your
house on fire okay everybody just keep
it cool everybody
Let's Chill Dino
let me know
three of us at the same time wow
I'm the police officer that was the
opposite of being a police officer we
just robbed somebody who robbed us the
universe is back on track baby we got
Grandma's earrings back and the rain
sticks
how are we doing on traffic green all
the way all right looks like we're
actually gonna make it in time for this
wedding thank you Universe thank you for
blessing this marriage
yep God damn it Universe I just have to
pump the gas twice and turn it back on
this happens all the time
oh boy this has never happened before
everybody out the universe wants you to
prove that you want to get married the
two
you can fly you can fly I'm a vessel for
the Universe
I can't believe you two aren't my
biggest problem today or not who is
match isn't she beautiful
oh my God I rolled two not a boat
um
we'll all be staring at her oh no wow oh
no what's happening someone told me
what's happening I got some more bad
news ah that thing's huge didn't Rosa
want things to be classy I mean she's
getting married not finishing a marathon
stay in your lane bucko right Santiago
the arch sucks
ouch the truth is every time I look at
it I want to die and take you with me
wow I wish you'd said something before I
spent all day making it of course you
didn't want to burst my bubble
and then
you did
oh oh yep
yep yeah Charles didn't sober up Rosa
she got him drunk oh no how drunk is he
remember the night they canceled
Bunheads oh no
18 shots of espresso it got me through
the first three months of having twins
but I imagine it'll sober you up too
she's taking care of you you're such a
good father oh I miss my father he used
to be daddy's little girl but we never
talk anymore you don't that's what
happens you grow up oh [ __ ] Terry don't
do it Terry read them stories do the
little pigtails really Serge who do you
think used to do my pigtails
why can't they stay babies
no
we need to get some of those you're a
train Pilots no I'm not I'm self-taught
what oh yeah you can learn anything
online oh you should see me do origami
oh do you know how to do a frog oh no
can you do a swan nope can you do a
crane what's a crane okay he does not
know how to fly a plank
how did the wedding go Terry what the
hell man you said you were gonna sober
them up it's your fault my girls are
never gonna grow up and lose their
virginity ah you're the nightmare you
made me kill my balloon baby
look at me so drunk I'm alliterating
like a beatnik
[Laughter]
just know that you brought this on
yourself
Hitchcock
the frost
will that actually do it I don't think
so Rosa got drunk I sent someone in to
help her she got them drunk too it's
like she was trying to tank this thing
yeah well pimento call off the wedding
three times because of the universe if I
didn't know them any better I think they
don't even want to get married no
no they don't want to get married
but everyone's here I suppose I can see
how a balloon arch might have been a
little too much oh yeah for sure no
you're supposed to say this wedding
looks like garbage this wedding looks
like garbage no no
as long as the brine's happy
[Laughter]
thanks Amy I'm super nervous kind of
wish I was still drunk yeah I
why are you packing the Bellini what I
think I'm trying to sabotage my own
wedding I don't know were you I don't
know something just doesn't feel right
oh man I gotta talk to Adrian I was my
own sign the whole time wow that's a
real M Night Shyamalan twist signs wait
do you think he's behind all of this I
do not yep I should go talk to Rosa
thanks Jake signs Charles in the
background we have an announcement to
make we're not getting married oh you
can shove those odds up your butts yeah
or I'll come out there and I'll do it
for you what an interesting event
we love each other but
we haven't even really spent that much
time together we've never been on a real
date so we're gonna start there
it's good in just 14 hours Amy put
together the most amazing non-wetting
wedding in history better than sleep is
in Seattle nope that is also Nora Ephron
kill yourself
[Laughter]
kill yourself
um I just wanted to thank you for all
your help yesterday I didn't do much it
was nothing good day oh my God does he
have a balloon arch
a balloon arch oh my God Captain she is
magnificent
indication
Vindication yes yes yes yes victory for
Captain Holt beautiful absolutely
beautiful that was a delight good to
have pimento back that's right all right
calling off my wedding now yes he's
excited television can be very
influential people very persuasive and I
have decided that now it is decided yes
yeah I'm doing it the signs are all
there the universe is telling you yeah
yeah
um oh wait
um hold on
I'll be right back okay
sure yeah this is a delight a delightful
Ensemble piece and uh especially on the
heels of Halloween to have Adrian
pimento back it's such a lovely treat
especially segwaying into his appearance
within monster in the closet gag I
thought that was a hilarious cold open
and yes just getting right back into it
uh you know I really liked the way that
the you know the idea of the plot of
this episode complemented both the
hijinks as well as the emotional stuff I
think Brooklyn Nine-Nine is often at its
best when it is you know really honing
in on the characters yes the situations
are often amusing and funny and quirky
and whatnot but yeah when it's really
character motivated and it's about you
know the unique relationships of The
Ensemble I think that's when they sing
the most and I feel like this episode
certainly did that uh yeah what did you
think sir or think yeah when you have
character moments own those things and
emotional yeah this is this is a really
nice blend of the two for me I really
enjoy it definitely uh yeah I was
thinking that too what the wedding did
to everybody and uh I had to get my ring
because it was like okay now that I'm
making this joke I'm also realizing I'm
not wearing my ring right now this is a
bad look
just misses you know happens to watch
the video and I'm like I got to explain
the whole joke
so you know I'm learning learning I'm
ahead of the curve here on what you got
to do where was it did you have to go
far
now it's right outside the door I just
let you do your thing cool
I left it on the floor outside leave it
outside I use it as a door stopper yeah
it's very heavy ring
um yeah I know I thought this was a
really well done episode and I I think
they
they set up a scenario that's very
sitcom scenario that I've seen played
out a bunch like we're getting married
we're getting hitched too early oh no
what do we do everyone's here let's call
off the wedding and you have to the last
minute every sitcom's like
you gotta go put together we're waiting
last minute and it's all chaos right but
what I think they did very well here
with a traditional setup type of episode
is they completely they know their
characters so well that it's all
executed in the way how these characters
would do it
like even right down to them of how they
lead up to the wedding with them going
into denial and the way they're acting
out and blaming other things without
realizing like I'm actually
self-sabotaging but even right down a
while they cancel the wedding and how
they inform everyone I thought was
really funny of being like kind of
cutthroat being a little ruthless and
straightforward and extremely blunt
They're Gonna Keep the presence and if
anyone has a problem then they can meet
them out of the parking lot like they're
still really tough about it and like
yeah I guess or you just keep the
present ceremon I don't do anything
about it and also how it allowed
opportunities for when getting with
ready for the wedding to see
to see different shades of our
characters that we don't often get to
spend much time with like I wasn't aware
of Boyle and
Genevieve not getting married and I was
like oh that's right she does come from
a divorce but you know Terry of course
dealing with the fact that his
daughter's growing up always having a
crisis of being a dad but then hold with
the balloons was so hilarious and the
archway was so really funny uh yeah I
thought that was great I'm surprised
we're not doing anything about the pawn
shop case so that's a real it's a real
crime that woman committed it's a
full-on crime and they have all the
evidence and support that it's a full-on
crime yes they broke and entered but at
the same time they this lady did
something awful and they should at least
contact the local Precinct and let them
know about it yeah might as well even if
it's outside their jurisdiction at least
an anonymous tip would go pretty far I
think there was an arson
yeah you think they would do as their
Duty as officers but I guess they're not
I guess it was just used for comedic
hijinks again that's why I gotta defund
the police and they also did that crime
I'm saying given an anonymous tip yeah
that's probably the better their crime
was them stealing back what they other
than what Gina did their crime is them
taking back what's rightfully theirs
yeah all the their only real crime is
they went into a home got into yeah but
other than that you know
they were just trying to take back with
what belonged to them that's true and
they committed a full-on crime they got
a snitch on the criminals you know what
I mean that's right definitely we got to
fund the police
it's a very regrettable I like that
where do I lie yeah you appealed every
denial thing every denomination every
single ideology so yeah no this is a
really really fun episode and it makes
me look forward to the day when Jake and
Amy get married yeah you know it's
inevitable it's an inevitability it has
to happen does this mean that uh I could
see them just uh writing out pimento one
day just like just as a joke like I'm
gone all right I'm here I'm gone yeah
yeah I I've learned that we should just
appreciate any and all pimento
appearances for they you know could dry
up at any moment but you know the the
time spent is really the gift there and
I loved I don't know like having him
back was like it didn't skip a beat like
it used the Gap well to its Advantage
but also I just I love of what he brings
to the overall Ensemble and and having
him and Jake and Gina as a trio I
thought was a nice uh you know waited to
to orchestrate that plotline like I love
pimento and Jake anyway but having Gina
there is the sort of middle entity
between their sensibilities I think made
for a really nice uh yeah
full not quite foil but yeah like a nice
go-between for their Dynamic well Gina
knows pimento she knows how to speak his
language he knows how to communicate
with him yeah if anything this shows
really demonstrate pimento's really good
at connecting with women sure the men
are always like
this is a weird guy how do I deal with
you
Rosa and Gina both know how to speak
their own kind of language with pimento
pretty well yeah and I think the lately
it seems like too especially in this
season I know we were talking last
season about there being certain
instances where it's like oh you know
like I wish they would elaborate on on
for example like this beat with Amy like
okay she's always the butt of a joke
because of her you know straight laced
ways uh but I think they've done really
well to utilize those character beats in
more interesting and more uh
in like richer ways where it's like okay
I love how Rosa and Amy kind of bond
because of the things that you know Rosa
would have ribbed Amy for before now
they've figured out how to kind of
harmonize the things that are super
different about the character so that
you do still get some of that you know
humorous tension but also uh I feel like
they're better at making the characters
feel alive and using their you know sets
of personality traits in ways that are
yeah a bit less of like okay I know what
the joke is going to be with this person
it's more like okay I know that's a
quality of their character I know there
will be humor attached to it but uh yeah
they they feel a bit more alive and like
they're using those uh beats a bit more
conscientiously which I really liked
like I love that this just this sets off
and it's just like Amy this is exactly a
you task get going and then you have
great opportunities for like subversion
within that like I love the Hitchcock
and Scully stuff and yeah even Rose is
getting everybody drunk like they use
really great subversion throughout this
and I feel like that's been an asset
overall this season you know kind of
moving around
yeah I mean
comedy show
supposed to subvert
well they're doing a good job of it
sometimes sometimes before they wouldn't
basic one-on-one comedy yeah basic class
comedy sure class comedy
all the poor and rich people have
somebody retirement season three four
you should
of our expectations yes I agree
I'll make sure they do so moving forward
because it's my fault
all right guys Brooklyn Nine-Nine thanks
for being here
much love to everyone appreciate all the
sort of support on patreon let's end
this with a patreon
Adelia Chamberlain
Adelia it's Thanksgiving time it's the
perfect time to give thanks and uh going
through our our list here today I was
realizing that we have a small handful
of people who have just never swayed
away from our patreon page and have just
remained so loyal to us like we're
always saying stuff like loyal citizen
or whatever loyal subscriber you know a
flowery talk but the truth is there's
there really is just a handful of people
who've been in insanely loyal and no
matter what like I know life can get
rough for you in in many ways and yet
you've always been so constant in our
lives and I appreciate that about you
being here with us
first for God I don't I don't know is
there a date here
clicker clicker actual date here
65 months it says that's such a long
time yeah that's like over a year yeah
that's what it's well over again
that's several years I mean at least a
few the world uh that is just gnarly to
me so yeah thank you for the support and
for your insights and kindness and then
the fact that you'll like reach out and
just want to talk and have real
conversations and you've always just
been very real so thank you for being a
genuine spirit and
yeah I mean one more is it saying you
you [ __ ] rock thanks for being here
[Music]